[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So we'll
get right into it.
Bob spent decades at Walt Disney
Imagineering back in the day
when it was WED.
So we're going to go through his
time there, working with Walt,
building Disneyland, and some
of the most infamous rides.
So we'll get right into it, Bob.
BOB GURR: Infamous?
No, they were classic.
[LAUGH]
MALE SPEAKER: So
they were classy.
Classy rides.
And so we'll get right into it.
So Bob, you went to
school at the Art Center
College of Design in LA.
And you ended up going to
General Motors and to Ford.
And so what kind of
got you into Disney?
BOB GURR: General Motors
scholarship, hired by Ford.
Speak about burning bridges.
[LAUGH]
MALE SPEAKER: So what was
the transition from there
into-- so how did
Walt find you, how
did you get into Imagineering?
BOB GURR: Very simple.
I was at the Art Center
College, the one over there.
And there was a guy who was a
job placement officer who had
placed me at Ford years ago.
Happened to ask, do
you do outside work?
I didn't, but I said yes.
That's the first clue
you want to do in life.
Next day-- that was only the
22nd meeting, by the way.
Next day, I got a call.
Go to the Disney studio
and meet Mr. Irvine there
in about 20 minutes.
Boy, I had seen an article
in the "Los Angeles Times"
some weeks before of a
thing called Disney Land.
And I thought, wow.
That would be a fabulous
place to go some day.
Then I was also friends
with Ub Iwerks, who
was the man who started
the company with Walt.
And he shows movies of what's
going on in the back lot.
And there was a little
chassis of a car.
No body.
And I thought, you
don't suppose they
need a body on a little car,
and I'm a body designer?
That was a good guess.
And I went to work, and 27
years later when they fired me,
I got all those jobs done.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, that's 45 seconds of life.
MALE SPEAKER: There we go.
And we're done.
There we go.
[LAUGH]
So that's incredible.
So when you heard about
that Disneyland was coming
and you were getting
involved, did it just
seem like a crazy idea?
Because it really
hadn't been done before.
BOB GURR: No.
You've got to realize, there was
no such thing as Theme Park 101
in college.
Everything that
everybody was going to do
had never been done before.
So it didn't matter what
you were educated at,
you weren't going to use
your education anyway.
Walt was always
going to give out
requests to do this and do
this and figure things out.
And he'd never done it
either, of course, you know.
But he had done
animation in films.
But now he wanted to do
a brick and mortar park,
and it was quite radical.
So basically, he figured
out what kind of people
might be able to do the
things he wanted done.
And he was very typical, when
he would ask you to do something
and it was something you'd
never done before-- like,
we had animators who
had never sculpted,
and then Walt said, well, I
think you'd be a good sculptor.
Why don't you just start?
That's how he
would treat people.
And of course in my case, since
I was trained in body design,
just let's say the surface
development part of a car,
Walt assumed that if
I did auto styling,
I did mechanical engineering.
[LAUGH]
I just shut up and
just kept working.
And it turned out, I have no
mechanical engineering training
whatsoever, but I got the best
by actually doing the job
that I wasn't qualified for.
Now stop and think of that.
[LAUGH]
No, really.
If you were to go to a
school, you have a curriculum,
you come out of it--
four years, you'll
come out the other end like
your trained in a deep trough,
and you can't get
out, but you know
how to do what they
taught you to do.
Your mind-- there's
no more flexibility.
But under Walt Disney and with
people that he would gather,
people were free to
think in all directions
in any combination, any time,
to try to figure stuff out.
That seemed to be the giant
clue around Walt Disney
that you just don't
see in a lot of people.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
And so what was it like
to work with him when
you first initially met him?
Because obviously, he was really
famous, really well known.
So what kind of man was
he like to work with?
BOB GURR: On one hand,
he was very serious.
And on the other hand, when he
was excited about something,
that little eyebrow
would just shoot up.
And he had that little
twinkle in his eye like,
oh, I'm going to have
something nobody's got.
Wait till I show the
world this thing.
So kind of a pixie-like thing.
But day in, day out
I would say he's kind
of slightly serious, slightly
agitated a little bit.
And I think the
source of that was,
like, you run across a lot
of people that are like that,
they are thinking the whole time
of what they're going to do.
And it's such a consuming thing,
almost like 24 hours a day.
I think at night, some of
us-- we think all night long
and we wake up and
go, oh, I got it.
I got it.
Write it down real quick.
Then I got to go to work in the
morning and hope I remember it.
His mind worked like that.
And a lot of people-- he
collected work just like that.
It wasn't an eight
hour type of day.
Walt also had another
characteristic
that was kind of fascinating
and very natural,
and I've seen other executives
in later years do this.
Instead of having a
classical management
matrix where you have an officer
at the top of the company,
you have workers down at the
lower part of the company,
the information goes down,
information turns around,
comes back, and it goes through
filters going both directions,
so you don't get
the true answer.
Walt would walk
out of his office
and walk around that whole
back lot at the studio,
see what's going on
with his own eyes.
Stop and think.
You won't be more than about
three days out of whack
before he'll notice you need
to do something a little bit
different.
The time saving is fabulous,
but here's the other thing.
Let's say you're
working on something
and you thought you
understood what you wanted,
and then he sees it, and
it's not what he wanted.
How many times you run
across a manager who says,
you do that dumb thing one more
time, I'm going to fire you.
I warned you.
Well, guess what?
You are not going to contribute
another idea to that guy.
You guys are different
up here, aren't you?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
we don't get fired.
BOB GURR: Yeah, right.
MALE SPEAKER: We just
get moved around.
BOB GURR: Yeah, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I notice you can
move people pretty far
away from where I used to live.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah Yeah, they still get
the bicycle [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, yeah.
But the way he would do it
is, let's say you're not
doing quite as expected.
He wouldn't chew you out.
He'd actually look at something
and he'd say, say, Bobby.
Did you ever think of-- oh, I
didn't think of that one, Walt.
Now you are-- you
can't wait to share
your new idea of his
new idea that just
happened 20 seconds before.
Now you've got this
rapport that's going on,
and you have a free exchange.
You understand?
That's how that kind
of a loop works.
That to him was natural, and
people that would work there,
it didn't take very
long before that
was their natural, daily MO.
Now I've also got to
remember, to a lot of people,
let's say even as
late as one 1954
when I started with the
company, a guy like Walt
would seem like a god.
In other words, I'm a
seriously-- a really famous,
famous person.
I would see times there'd be
executives at other companies.
They'd get too close to Walt and
their lower lip would quiver.
They didn't quite know how
to talk because they're
in the presence of Walt Disney.
The god, you know?
Walt did everything possible
to make himself approachable.
He'd unloosen his tie and make
himself look kind of ratty
so as he could have
a conversation.
And he would always
point out to people,
he says, well, you know,
to get this stuff done,
I have to talk to
people, you know?
And so the rhythm in
the company always
developed all over a while.
Took a couple of
weeks to get used
to the fact that, oh, my God.
Here comes Walt. Now it's a
case of, hiya, Walt. It's just
as simple as that.
Because now you have to have--
everybody's on that same level.
Now you can have a critique,
and the design is good
or the design is bad,
or needs some work.
Now if the design was good,
what you're doing is good,
Walt would simply walk in.
He'd just look around.
Sometimes he
wouldn't say a word.
He'd just walk around.
He'd look at your drafting
board or maybe say something,
and he'd walk out.
About five minutes later,
the guy down the hall
would come and run into the
room and says, what is it
you're doing?
Walt just came in
and said, you gotta
go see what Gurr's
doing down there.
That's your attaboy.
Now see, he never gave a
personal attaboy to anybody.
You just don't do that.
But he couldn't wait
to go tell somebody
else how good your stuff was.
So this was a very strange
kind of way to do that.
He had another characteristic
when he was coming down
the hallway to go to your room.
You see that little cough?
He had a little double cough.
And this was like you had
the 10 second warning.
You know, clean up your
act real quick there.
Your door's always open.
You never leave a
closed door there,
because he will show up at
any time without warning
and in any building.
In particular, the shops.
He loved to run around in
the shops all the time.
So that's the general
set and setting.
That's a long way to
answer, what was Walt
like to work with?
A lot of people today
will say, well, no.
That was 50 years ago.
People don't work like that.
Well, some years ago when
I had my own company later,
I worked for Steven Spielberg.
And he was running, like, $200
million worth of film product,
and he had, like, 46 employees.
He had a cute little set of
buildings out in Universal next
to a river.
He did exactly the same thing.
He talked the people
doing the work,
and he didn't have any
layers of management.
Another guy, Steve
Wynn in Las Vegas.
You know, he was like
the mogul of Las Vegas.
He talked directly to
people, and he wouldn't even
go through a
secretary if he wanted
to phone-- if he had a question,
he'd just phone you up.
And remember, that's the guy
that's running the Mirage.
He was running
later the Bellagio,
and now he's got two
more Wynn hotels.
Spielberg and Wynn
and Walt, they're
very similar kind of
guys to work with.
They understood this thing,
that tight communication,
not being driven by
methodologies or procedures
or protocols.
That's the big lesson.
Now when I walk around
this place here,
I'm still just like
going, I'm in Google.
I'm in Google.
You know, it's like
everything I see here
is like, I was born
60 years too late.
Now I can't be here, you, know?
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: But you built
Disneyland, I'm pretty sure.
BOB GURR: Yeah, I
built Disneyland.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER: You win.
BOB GURR: No, but
this is-- this is
so much like the early days
of what was then called
WED Enterprise,
Walter Elias Disney.
It's almost eerie.
And I look around and I
see bright looking faces,
and it's like, it's is a
starting IQ of 180 here.
What is it?
MALE SPEAKER: That's not mine.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know why.
BOB GURR: No, but there's--
when you go to places,
you can see the enthusiasm
on people's faces.
I was-- two weeks
ago I was at SpaceX.
I got to see them build
rockets down there.
I met Elon Musk.
I'm being chauffeured today on
a Tesla S. I think it's a D85.
Is that a D85?
Ooh.
He's going to give me the full
pedal this weekend, I think.
[LAUGH]
No, but there are companies
that remind me so much
of Walt's time a long time ago.
And if you understand what
that spark is up here-- I'm
guessing you have some
management that, you know,
what?
17 years, started with a
couple of geeks, and look.
You've got 17,000
geeks up here now.
[LAUGHTER]
And it looks like
you're having fun,
but you're productive
at the same time.
Well, that's the way we used
to do it so long ago to get
Disneyland built that fast.
OK.
You got another question?
MALE SPEAKER: I got a few more.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
No, I mean, you've
really-- I mean,
you've designed some of
the most incredible rides.
I mean, you did Autopia.
That was your first
project, right?
BOB GURR: Autopia car, yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
And so what was kind of that
process in designing that?
Was that just
simply, well, you're
just going to design cars?
Like, what was the idea?
How big to make them, and how--
you know, how to make them run?
BOB GURR: Did you just
hear what you just said?
MALE SPEAKER: I don't know.
BOB GURR: Process.
MALE SPEAKER: Process.
BOB GURR: (ACCENTED)
We don't use processes.
[LAUGH]
We just do it.
MALE SPEAKER: Just do it.
BOB GURR: Yeah.
That's a bad word.
Everybody has to be processed.
Then I stare at people.
I say, process.
[LAUGH]
That's the bad word.
That's like being in a rut.
Smart people, given a
question and you've never
done it before, you don't
get there with a process.
You get there by clear
thinking, off the wall thinking.
You know, French cats bouncing
off a wall type of thinking.
And you do that with everybody
around you, and guess what?
The configuration's
going to work.
Gradually becomes
very, very visible.
And it's never
done by a process.
Ordinary companies
are process companies.
So don't use that
word on me again.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
BOB GURR: All right.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So no process.
So there was no process involved
with creating the animatronics.
But you did get
involved with that,
so I want to talk about that.
Because that's some
incredible work
that you've done, with
Disney and with Universal.
BOB GURR: Well, the audio
animatronics-- remember, I
was known as a car guy
because I fiddled around
with cars in high school.
I rebuilt my own engines
and stuff like that.
So I had a working
knowledge of cars, anyway.
And after a number
of years, we were
doing work for the
New York World's Fair
in which I was in charge
of designing the Ford Magic
Skyway, which is a great big
assembly line of cars being
moved by wheels with passengers,
using regular passenger cars.
It was about a three year
job to engineer that thing.
And I was working on two
of the other attractions.
And at the last minute, about
for five months before the park
was-- or the show, the fair
was going to open, Walt says,
Bobby, I want you to
design Abraham Lincoln,
the body of it.
We've got one here.
We've been working
on it for a year.
Doesn't work.
The head works, the hands
work, but the body won't work.
And I thought, I
don't know anything
about human physiology.
[LAUGH]
And Lincoln doesn't have
any wheels, you know?
But guess what?
In maybe a minute I looked
at that Lincoln that was not
working, and I saw it
as an aircraft fuselage
made out of thin
walled steel tube
with little pneumatic
cylinders, a few hydraulics
cylinders, little Fafnir
aircraft bearings.
I did not see it as a
human, and I did not
see it in the way
the machine had
been evolved in a design
in the machine shop.
That's an example when I'm
talking about free thinking
that had I not been
a free thinker,
I would have not
had the direction
to go within about two
minutes from the time Walt
asked me to do that.
I was in a glider club.
I just happened to have
a steel tube fuselage
aircraft that was restoring.
And I immediately saw,
that's the way to do it.
How many people have ever
been to the Walt Disney Family
Museum up here?
Well, OK.
Did you see downstairs,
there's an exhibit
with Abraham Lincoln?
Nobody remembers seeing that.
Oh, you did.
OK.
In that little window,
there's a steel tube frame.
That's the original upper
body of Abraham Lincoln.
Was the first one to be shown
at the New York World's Fair.
That was the high
point of Walt's pride
in doing auto animatronics, and
he asked a car guy to do it.
[LAUGHTER]
Now see, the education
still wouldn't have helped.
Yeah.
Because we were
all free thinkers.
Anyway, I owned that thing.
I loaned it to him
up there, so it's
kind of like a permanent loan.
So if you haven't been
there, if you really
want to see a simple way
to do an animated figure,
50 years ago that's what we did.
MALE SPEAKER: So
you've obviously
been to the parks
since then obviously,
since you worked there.
So what impresses you now
about how animatronics
work now and the parks,
and some of lands
and stuff they're doing?
BOB GURR: The evolution of
audio animatronics, which
is a trade name that
Disney company uses,
has been constant
evolution all the time.
We were sort of the
leading edge of doing
the first types of rob-- what
we would call robotic animation.
We were using some of the latest
systems for serviles, controls,
feedback methodologies that
were used in the space program
for going to the moon.
So there was parts and systems
and components coming online
basically for NASA
at that time, and we
had access to all that stuff.
Walt was always very aware
of the latest tools, a way
to tell stories.
So this was a very
natural progression.
It went very, very fast.
And by I would say
in 1972 or 1973,
we developed our own system
called DACS, Digital Animation
Control System.
So we were doing a
lot of development
in-house, leading edge stuff.
But as time went on, the rest
of the world kind of caught up.
Everybody can do this now.
And actually, the way we
do it now, we actually
have a company called
Garner Holt Productions out
in San Bernardino, California.
Disney lets them do all of
the developmental work for all
of our theme parks
worldwide, because they're
more like a production house,
and we have the systems
that are all available.
A lot of the show control
systems are standard,
let's say, black boxes you
can buy from anybody now.
So we're very standardized
in that respect.
We really don't have to
invent serious stuff anymore
because there's such
an array of stuff
that you can use nowadays.
So yes.
There is that kind of a
transition, the development
of audio animatronics.
So it's much more
productionized now.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So can you talk about the
design of the monorail, which
is just a huge feature?
And it's still around Disneyland
and Disney World today.
BOB GURR: How many of you ever
rode the Disneyland monorail?
Oh, all hands come up.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
Yeah.
I had never seen that
configuration of a monorail.
And going back
the way Walt would
ask somebody do something,
he walks in in October 1958.
Walks in, shows me these
pictures of a really ugly
looking train sitting on a--
looked like a loaf of bread
with a slot in the bottom
sitting on a stick.
And he says, Bobby, we're going
to build a monorail system
in Disneyland, and I want you
to get started right away on it.
And walked out of the room.
He left me these pictures
of this ugly thing.
And I had never seen
that configuration.
I thought they always hung, you
know, from an overhead beam.
And again, there you are.
We're sitting area like,
that wasn't even a meeting.
Well, I start.
I'm going to start.
And guess what?
If you are a curious
person and you've
spent all your time
snooping into everything
you can snoop into and
putting it on your head,
and you may never
use it, but you
might use it someday--
and remember,
I'm going back to auto shop,
car kid, all that kind of stuff.
Hanging around with race cars.
I had a broad brush idea
of how stuff sort of works.
A monorail is nothing more
than a strange looking bus.
The wheels are simply in line.
They sit on top of the
road, and then there's
wheels running on the side.
But they've still got
seats, doors, and windows,
and people sitting in it.
OK.
It's like a streetcar.
Oh, well, you can buy
that stuff, you know.
It's a 600 volt power systems.
You put 450 volt motors
together of a suspension system.
I knew how these
gravel trucks worked.
At that time there
was a thing called
a Smithway, which was kind of an
all-in-one unitized suspension.
And within two weeks,
I had enough drawings
that I made that my boss
and I were sent over
to Germany to talk to
the Allway company, who
we were going to work with.
And I had enough of the design
that we could discuss it
in a lot of detail.
And then the Germans
knew that they were going
to sell their design to us.
And Walt said, no.
We're going to use your idea,
but it's going to be my train,
and we're going to
do it ourselves.
And then at the
end of the week it
was, Mr. Gurr is not a
licensed diploma engineer.
He cannot do this.
[LAUGH]
You're a movie studio.
Well, yeah.
But I'm doing it.
[LAUGHTER]
True story.
And that's how
fast we would work.
Now remember, that was
eight and a half months
from the time Walt
gave me the picture.
And we jumped on the thing.
And I had about five
drafters helping me.
And we figured the
whole darn thing out.
And we had a shop
starting to build it
and a commercial
company that built
garbage trucks that was closed.
Halfway through the job,
they were going too slow.
So we just picked the job
up, put it in the studio.
We had a big sound stage,
which was a factory.
So my boss said,
keep drawing it up,
but now you supervise
the construction.
Eight and a half months.
The whole darn thing.
And opening day, I
gave Richard Nixon,
the vice president of the
United States, a ride on it.
No estimating, no budgeting,
nobody interfering,
no project manager,
no coordinators.
Everybody doing the work talked
to everybody all day long.
Everybody from the shop level
to people doing the concrete
designs.
That's how fast you
can go if you're
a completely free
thinker and you've
been given something
you know nothing about.
And everybody was
just like that.
MALE SPEAKER: That's incredible.
What was your favorite
project to work on?
BOB GURR: Oh, the
little fire engine.
Anybody been down to Disney
and ride the fire engine?
That's my fire engine.
[LAUGHTER]
I always wanted a fire engine.
Ward Kimball was one
of Walt's animators.
He had a fire engine in
1916, American LaFrance,
and I got to drive it
in the parade once.
I always wanted a fire engine.
One day Walt was in my office
and I said, Walt, you know,
we don't have a fire
engine on Main Street.
No, Bobby, we don't.
And about 10 minutes later,
the accounting department
phones up, says, the accounting
project number for the new fire
engine project is--
and I thought, yes!
[LAUGHTER]
You know, I finally
have a fire engine.
We built it at a
studio in Burbank.
And I got a DMV
moving permit, and I
drove that thing down the Santa
Ana Freeway-- two cylinder car.
Drove it all the way
to Disney, because that
was my fire engine.
Yeah.
You asked me a question.
What's my best attraction?
That's it.
Yeah.
[LAUGH]
MALE SPEAKER: And then
was there ever a project
that you guys just
couldn't figure out
and didn't end up in Disneyland?
BOB GURR: You know,
the curious thing.
Today you run across so
many companies and projects
that they just grind
into a terrible grind,
and they just don't work.
And then when they do work,
they are just miserable
the whole time, and
then you take them out.
Walt somehow had a
sixth sense of about,
how far should you go into
the future in any given
direction that was not so far
that regular folks couldn't
do it?
You couple that with a
reasonable overall starting
configuration of a
project or a system.
Well, what that means is that
you didn't reach out too far.
By the time you get the work
spread out to everybody,
everybody finds they can do
that stuff in a lot of detail
because you didn't reach so far.
So every time I hear
the word nowadays
and somebody says, well, we have
the sophisticated engineers,
and oh, you know, oh, no.
Don't use the word
sophistication.
Sophistication means it's about
120% out instead of 110% out.
And you're going to have trouble
later because any fool can
convince the government to
spend money on a crazy idea,
because the words are
terrific, but the parts stink.
It's as simple as that.
So that initial configuration
on how far you reach
is super critical, and
Walt was so good at that.
So what I'm trying
to suggest to you
is I can't recall any blind
alley we every went up,
at least while I was working
there, because we were launched
correctly.
MALE SPEAKER: And so we're
going to take questions
here in a few minutes
if you guys want
to start lining up at the mic.
What was-- if you're looking
in the parks today, Disneyland,
Disney World, what part
or land or anything
would you like to
get involved with?
BOB GURR: I'd like to
personally tear down all
of Tomorrowland at Disneyland.
MALE SPEAKER: This
would be universal.
[APPLAUSE]
BOB GURR: Ah.
Maybe you're thinking
the same here.
That whole northeast
corner of the park
could be something
that is somewhere
between like an avatar
and a space tour,
space-- any kind of a thing,
but with a lot of greenery,
a lot of logic, a lot of
human scale stuff that's
visually very inspiring.
But it would still
have a monorail.
It would still have Autopia
because, you know, bump cars.
But Tesla's going to
make them, aren't they?
They're going to make the little
Teslas for all the little kids,
you know?
But I would like to see
something that really dramatic,
dynamic, but has an
inviting scale to it.
It's kind of hard
to do, but in words,
that's what I would-- if I could
get away with it, I'd do that.
I tell everybody
we're going to do it.
Yeah.
I'm going to wear them out.
MALE SPEAKER: How much
involvement do you have still
with Disney on their parks?
Do you still advise on anything?
BOB GURR: No.
Work is a four letter
word, and I don't do it.
[LAUGHTER]
I do have a simple rule.
If somebody wants me to
take a look at a project,
buy me a bowl of
soup at Mimi's Cafe.
I'll take a look.
But otherwise, work, if I
have to give out an invoice,
then that's revenue, and I
don't get into any of that.
No.
I'd rather go take a
look and look at stuff.
And I'm asked all the time.
But like what we're doing here
today, a lot of times people
will come up and
say, why don't you
es-plain how you guys did that
stuff so fast 50 years ago?
We're slow and expensive.
Can you help us?
So that happens all the time.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So for you
post-Disney, what was-- like,
why did you leave Disney?
Was it just time to go and
just, hey, start my own thing?
Because you did start your own
company after you left Disney.
BOB GURR: Yeah, they fired me.
[LAUGH]
No, really.
I got in a dispute with a
chief engineer of the company.
A simple thing.
We were having some great
difficulties building Epcot.
And we had a lot of engineers.
By that time were
aerospace engineers
who were process people.
We had so much engineering that
by the time I went to the shop,
none of that stuff would
work, and some of the people
were really tearing
their hair out.
And then in a meeting
somebody said, who can tell us
why this is happening?
And I said, I can tell you.
And then the other
people fled the room
except for the chief engineer.
I didn't realize I
insulted the man.
And I was fired.
Simple as that.
Because basically I
said, well, you know,
we used to talk to the
mechanics down at Disneyland,
and we'd get the
feedback from the field
as to how your systems
and parts worked
in very, very great detail.
You can't wear a tie
and be an engineer
and go down to Disneyland
and go talk to the mechanics.
You've got to be a
guy just like them.
They know the most
about your design,
and they can be obstinate
and not tell you.
Or you can befriend them
and they'll say, "Say Bob,
you know this bearing, the way
you got that thing moving-- I
want to show you how
it really works."
That's the guy you
want to listen to.
I explained that to
this chief engineer.
And he looked at me
and he said-- words
to the effect-- he
says, no grease monkey
is ever going to tell
my licensed engineers
how to design anything.
And I thought, whoo.
I was glad they fired me,
because within two weeks,
I was president of the
Gurr Design Incorporated.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
As you can see, you see
some projects over here
that are not Disney
like a sinking
ship in Las Vegas, a flying
saucer in the Olympics.
LA has that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
Branching out and
doing more work.
I loved having somebody
coming to me with something
that had never been done
before, that was so risky nobody
else wanted to do it.
And if it's that
risky, I'll take it.
Guess what?
No, this is an invitation for
you to expand your mind more.
You've had a lifetime.
You're not afraid to
do some of this stuff.
And you kind of know
how far out is too far.
Somebody'd bring me a
crazy job, and I said,
no, it's not going to
work, and I wouldn't do it.
But they'd did bring
an idea, and it
was like-- well,
Steve Wynn says,
I want to sink a ship
on Las Vegas Boulevard,
and it's burning down
while it's sinking,
and it's got people on it.
Yeah, Steve.
There's quite a few
ways we could do that.
[LAUGHTER]
See the difference between
saying, that's too risky,
we don't do it?
No, you turn it
around the other way.
But you've got a lot of projects
you've worked up here that some
of them didn't go too far.
But some of them
went so far, there's
Google stuff we
live on in the world
that we can't live without.
And that all had to come
from a goofy idea, you know?
And you guys were not
afraid to do that.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, you did
some consulting with Spielberg
on "Jurassic Park" with the
first T-Rex animatronic, right?
So what was that process?
Did you kind of apply the same--
BOB GURR: (MONOTONE
VOICE) Pro cess.
MALE SPEAKER: Pro-- ah.
You called me out
on it before he did.
So what was it like
to work on a dinosaur?
I mean, that's even
bigger than Abe Lincoln.
BOB GURR: Well, Steven called,
and he says, how soon can you
come talk to me?
I just bought a book.
It's not in print yet.
It's called "Jurassic Park."
I'll give you a galley proof.
I still have the
galley proof printed
one side only on the pages.
And he says, I talked
to my guys and they
said, oh, don't do anything
that big, hydraulic.
This stuff doesn't work.
Dino de Laurentiis' King Kong
didn't work worth a darn.
I designed the King Kong
for Universal in '86,
and it ran for 22 years.
It didn't really give
a lick of trouble.
Big machine.
The bigger they
get, they're easier,
because there's
more space inside.
And he says, I saw it.
It runs.
Come talk to me.
So he was working
with companies that
do what we call stick
puppetry, where in other words,
guys are standing
under a grating
and waving a stick
around for animals.
This was all before CGI.
But they want to do a 30
foot tall Tyrannosaurus Rex.
So I went out and I
worked out with him.
Then I worked with Stan Winston
Studio who later got the job.
And I had a couple of guys
that helped me with King Kong.
They want to work for them to
keep the technology moving.
But again, it was
a case of, there
was no fear to do
a thing like that,
because it was not outrageous.
And they built it.
And they once broke
a bearing one night,
so we had a down time
of about four hours
when they were
shooting the thing.
But that's the kind
of stuff, working
with a guy like Spielberg.
He's on the job every
day, talking to everybody
what they're doing.
That's the way stuff gets done.
MALE SPEAKER: All right So we'll
start opening up the audience
questions now.
AUDIENCE: Well, I was curious.
Like, how did the
other Imagineers
that you used to work with feel
when you got fired and left?
What was that experience like?
BOB GURR: They use
the expression,
did you see Gurr's bomb crater?
[LAUGHTER]
Well, it scared some
people because they
knew I was outspoken.
I was always outspoken.
It's just the way--
if you have opinions
and you have
observations and you
have a lot of life
experiences that work--
and again, a lot of people
were diploma trained engineers.
And they just had an attitude,
well, he's not qualified,
you know?
He doesn't have the diploma.
He doesn't do stuff like that.
I just do it anyway.
So there was a mixed emotion.
But over time, it turned
out to be very, very funny.
People still would talk to
other people and say, you know,
they fired him, but look what
he did after he got fired.
There's another guy up in this
neighborhood here got fired.
Pixar, John Lasseter.
He got fired too.
And look what he went and did.
So a lot of times, you'll have
ornery people in a company that
don't necessarily behave
the way you're supposed to,
and they have
their own opinions.
And they will cycle through a
company, and some of volunteer
to leave, some of
them will get fired.
But that does show that
there's different paths
that people take.
But I know it does
irritate managers to have
those kind of employees.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then when
you became a Disney legend,
do you feel like that kind of
liberated you in everything
you did, or that experience?
BOB GURR: No, you
know the funny thing?
My basic pay was watching
the smiles on people's faces
when they go to an attraction.
And that's like-- well, like
when we opened King Kong up,
took the first ride, and I
watched the people coming out.
And the older
people were staring,
and the middle
people were clapping,
and the kids were crying.
[LAUGHTER]
Boy, a 30 foot tall gorilla.
I know all the parts are there.
And it's like, yes!
But when you have a legend
or a window on Main Street--
I've got a whole bunch
of awards for stuff.
It's nice to be recognized.
But the real
recognition is when you
go to someplace that your stuff
works, and it's still working,
and you're having a good time
watching them have a good time.
So that's the pay part.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
BOB GURR: OK.
Next.
AUDIENCE: So the Haunted
Mansion at Disneyland
has always been one of my
favorite attractions there.
As a kid, I was always awestruck
by just how unique it was.
And then as I grew up,
you still go through it,
and it's amazing when you try
to go through and actually
try to figure out how some
of these illusions were made.
Was there anything when
designing the Haunted Mansion
that-- there were
ideas that came up
that were just too out there
or too crazy to actually build?
BOB GURR: Well, if you know
the history of the Haunted
Mansion-- some of you
might be Disney fans,
might have read about that.
For a number of
years, Walt had a guy
by the name of Yale Gracie,
one of our free thinkers,
just figuring out
gags all the time.
So we had a string of gags.
And it was going to
be a walk-through.
But it was difficult to plan
guest flow in a walk-through.
Monsanto, the Voyage
Thru Inner Space.
Anybody remember that one?
Yeah, you've got to be a little
bit older to remember that one.
I suddenly had an idea
for a conveyor that
could have a car on it that
you could rotate the car
and pitch it up, pitch
it down, that you
could point the guest--
like going through a movie,
you could control the scenes.
And it would be an
endless chain of vehicles.
Well, the minute the people
working on the Haunted Mansion
gags, they said, oh.
We'll make it a ride.
Now we can control
the whole thing.
So it was an attraction
that came about maybe
in a year and a half,
but it was like 10 years
with ideas slowly forming.
So it's a curious combination
of a high speed conveyor
mixed in with a
bunch of illusions
that now became movie scenes.
AUDIENCE: Interesting.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: A couple questions.
When you talked about how
Disney would pop in and give you
some great idea to
start working on,
and it would happen
really quickly,
did you have other guys popping
in on you and telling you
what to do?
Or other people you
had to answer to?
How did that work?
[LAUGH]
BOB GURR: That's a good one.
I don't recall anybody
telling me what to do.
[LAUGH]
I'm just that kind of a person.
We all literally consulted
with one another.
Because what I said a little
bit earlier, in those days
we did not have
project managers.
We did not have coordinators.
Everybody doing the work
at all different levels,
the sum of them
chatting every day
was the project management team.
Stop and think about that.
A lot of times, companies will
have sometimes more managers
and coordinators than
they've actually got people
with their hands on a product.
That changes the cost
structure completely.
At one time, I became so
irritated with projects getting
slowed down, a coordinator
would come in and says, Bob,
I have to ask you these
questions and explain all this.
And every time I'd explain it,
they didn't know what it was,
and then I'd have to
explain the explanation.
And I said, what are you
going to do with this?
Well, I'm going to take
it and make a report,
and I'm going to give it
to our project manager.
Well, your hands are
not on the product.
If I stop and talk
to you, do you
realize you just
stopped the project?
My hands are on the project.
And that was a lesson that went
through that company so fast,
and we still used it
in later companies.
If you're doing the work,
you're part of the managers.
You're part of the
coordinators, and you don't need
everybody else to go do it.
You can't do that in all
companies, of course.
Some of this is very complex.
But that was a
principle that was
present in those
years, the speed of how
things got done so quick.
AUDIENCE: So how quickly did
that change after Disney died?
BOB GURR: It was not
because of Walt's passing.
It was more because Disney
was expanding quite rapidly
in the '70s, because we were
doing Walt Disney World,
getting ready to do Epcot.
And remember '90, '91,
the aerospace industry
kind of collapsed after
Gorbachev and Reagan agreed
to tear down the Wall, and
all that sort of stuff.
So we didn't have a
lot of military work.
So all these engineers,
they're all floating around,
and Disney started
picking them up.
They brought processes, oh.
I tell you, meeting an
aerospace engineer over 50 was,
oh, my God.
Just they don't think.
They just do.
They only do stuff
the way they do stuff.
And we hired an
awful lot of them.
And that was the
period where it got
very sluggish, very sluggish.
We're on probably our third
generation of Imagineers now.
And luckily, we do find
a lot of people that
didn't come out of aerospace.
They come out of very
enthusiastic types
of schools and trades
that they like to do.
So it's a little easier now.
But there was that
middle period,
because the way I told you.
AUDIENCE: One other question.
Can you talk about testing?
BOB GURR: Testing?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
When you were about to set these
attractions loose on people,
what gave you any
confidence that--
BOB GURR: Well, in the
case of the monorail,
I put the red train
on the beam two weeks
before we were going to
have the grand opening.
So we had two weeks to do
what we call test and adjust.
But in that case, the first
trip the monorail made, and I
was at the controls, it went
an eighth of an inch with a log
electrical explosion.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, and Walt was in the train.
But he just got out and
looked at me, and walked away.
[LAUGHTER]
No, that's all true story.
You got the book.
It's in the book there.
Every day for the
following two weeks,
the train ran and got
almost all the way around,
and then stopped, and
then we towed it in.
And so we came up with
a fix every night.
Machine shop worked
at night doing it.
The day before
the grand opening,
when the vice president
was going to come
take a ride in it, that's the
only time the train ran around
one full lap and didn't stop.
So I parked it.
So we were going
to cut the ribbon.
When we drive out of the
TV shot, and we're OK.
That's testing.
That's what we did.
[LAUGHTER]
We didn't have time to
train the operators.
We had them all hired.
So they made me a monorail
operator's costume
on the graveyard shift.
So I was the driver.
AUDIENCE: You didn't have SREs?
BOB GURR: Huh?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Well, nowadays the current--
AUDIENCE: Liability engineers?
[LAUGH]
BOB GURR: No.
No, really.
People were very sensible.
Safety is the absolute
number one stuff.
Remember, this thing's
up in the air, you know?
It's going to go
35 miles per hour,
and you don't want
anybody-- don't
want it to fall of the beam
or parts fall out of it.
You are always-- public
safety in amusement parks
is right in the
top of your head.
Every decision
you make in detail
is looking at the safety
of a ride operation.
It's kind of automatic.
You don't have somebody
doing that as a service.
You're doing it
internally because that's
what you have to do.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BOB GURR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so
you said that a lot
of the organizational
culture comes
from the people at the top.
So like you said, Steve Wynn
or John Lasseter or Walt
is sending those values down.
Like, as companies expand
and as leaders may or may not
have that philosophy, how do you
gain it if you don't have it,
and how do you keep
it going if you do?
BOB GURR: Yeah.
For your career, you
should be very smart
and research the company
you're going to join,
because they might have
dumb people at the top.
You want to find a company that
has smart thinkers at the top.
I think all of you
found that company.
It's a brutal way to
answer that question.
There are some companies.
Get going, and they're
just-- over time,
they're not really
good at what they do.
But there's a whole
bunch of other companies
that they just change
the world right and left.
There's something about
this part of the planet.
I don't know whether it's
the water or the air,
but there's a level of go
do stuff that's interesting
up in this area here.
I don't know quite what it
is, but it's very unique,
and there's a lot
of people gravitated
here just because of that.
That's probably not an answer,
but that's my observation.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BOB GURR: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Bob.
I worked at Disneyland
for two summers,
and it was just a thrill working
around all your achievements
and works, so thank you.
I guess I'm wondering,
how did you collaborate
with animators or kind
of the arts department,
just to kind of gel art
and engineering together?
BOB GURR: Remember what
I was saying earlier.
We all talked to one
another all the time.
It was a very common
thing that since we
didn't have what we would
call a matrix organization,
if you wanted to know something,
go find out who's got it
and go find out where
you can find them.
And we just really walked
all over that studio lot.
We still do that at Walt
Disney Imagineering,
which is now in Glendale.
You don't necessarily have
to wait for a meeting.
Go call somebody up or
go over and talk to them.
You don't have to go with a
manager or anything like that.
Just go ask.
AUDIENCE: What would
come first usually?
Like a technical idea,
or an artistic one?
BOB GURR: It's a blend.
I mentioned earlier, Walt
was very technically savvy
about new techniques, new
tools, stuff like that.
And he could see how
you could take a tool
and help tell a story
in an improved way.
And that was a blend
coming out of movies,
coming out of animation.
Because remember, he did both
film and hand drawn animation.
And of course, the company's
gone on past all that
with Pixar, because it's
a lot of CGI nowadays.
But it's a blend.
Remember, we're still
telling the story.
You know, if it's "Toy Story"
with Pixar and John Lasseter,
that's a story.
Movies done exactly
the same way.
You go to Disneyland, you go
to, like, the pirate ride.
That's a story.
We're telling stories.
We just happen to do it in
physical 3D without glasses.
You ride in the boat,
and that's a story.
So that's a common thread.
It doesn't matter whether it's
animation, mechanical, writing,
or whatever.
It's storytelling.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So when
you were building
new rides and new
things, how did you
balance between design and
drawing and the planning side,
versus having somebody
just go experiment, fiddle,
and see what they can build?
BOB GURR: Yeah, we
did all of that.
And we didn't necessarily have
departments that did that.
In the earlier days,
since everybody
was talking to one
another-- and we
had a very strange
way of running
WED Enterprise in those days--
the company deliberately
did not let any of
the creative people
learn what anything cost.
I mean that's really weird.
The interesting thing
was time was so tight.
Like when Walt would
start a project,
he'd set the day they were going
to call the media in and have
the grand opening,
and then you'd
work backwards with
everything to the present day.
And everybody
could automatically
see that, oh, my God.
We don't have any
time to waste here.
So you automatically
go fast, and you
didn't need to budget it.
Budgeting in a way
is almost foolish
because the guy doing the
budget has never built anything.
And the budget is
always going to be
blown up or down, either way.
So the point is,
don't have the budget.
Use your smarts and go fast
with your own intelligence.
And that works,
and that's the way
Disney got a lot of
stuff done in those days.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BOB GURR: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Are there any projects that you
wish you had gotten to first?
And are there any
that you might not
have been spearheading, but
that you feel you kind of made
a legendary contribution to?
BOB GURR: Ooh, that's a
kind of a complicated one.
You know, I never
basically originated
an attraction concept.
I was always the guy
that somebody went to
after they had an idea, where
it was in the word stage.
Primarily words, maybe
a little bit of artwork.
And then I would
see it, and then I'd
say, oh, I can see
how to do that.
But it was not where I
would be the guy that
would suggest the idea.
It's kind of a moot
question in the standpoint
that I did so many things,
such a big variety,
it'd be a tough one
to say which one would
I have liked it done
that was not done.
In Disney, I was
pretty much satisfied.
Everything I got a chance to do.
But in the mechanical
design area,
there was one thing I would
have always liked to do.
Design an animated
Rose Parade float
for the Tournament
of Roses in Pasadena.
But nobody called.
[LAUGHTER]
But I would talk my way into
the places that designed them
and do them, and climb up
inside them on a couple days
later when they were taking them
apart to see how they did it.
And I have a good
lady friend that
works over at one of the
biggest manufacturers of floats.
And they invite me over
several times in the year
so I can see the start
of the framework,
see how the covering's
done, then go and see
how they put all the flowers in.
So, yeah.
I know how that stuff's done.
It's really clever stuff.
But I just wish somebody
would have called.
I would [INAUDIBLE] done that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BOB GURR: All right.
How we doing on the time here?
MALE SPEAKER: We're
pretty good, actually.
BOB GURR: All right.
MALE SPEAKER: No
time, no budget.
BOB GURR: All right.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I have
two quick questions.
What do you look at when
you go to a theme park
today, whether it's a
Disney park or another down
the street?
Like, how do you
experience a theme park?
BOB GURR: OK.
I'll answer it in this way.
I was made a Lifetime--
what do they call them?
Life-- Lifetime something
for the Themed Entertainment
Association.
And if you have that
honor they give you,
you're automatically on the
awards committee for life.
And I've been on that committee
now-- gosh, since 1999.
And every year, we have
about 140 nominations
come in for
entertainment projects
of all kinds in the
themed business worldwide.
So this is my reconnaissance.
I get to snoop and see
what everybody is doing
and how they do it.
And in some cases, we go out and
actually look at the attraction
and go experience it.
So I'm in a position
that every year, I
can see what the entire
industry as a group is doing.
We have maybe 20 people
on our committee,
and they're all people
that are basically
presidents of companies or
lead designers of companies,
and some of them are like me.
They're retired legends
that come in there
and look at everything.
So it's interesting to follow
this constant improvement
of everything.
Now specifically it was
a specific theme park,
as you know, Themed
Entertainment Association
has given out two
awards in two past years
for the Wizarding World of Harry
Potter at Universal, Florida.
And then most
recently, Diagon Alley.
So when I go to those
places, I'm sort of like,
how come Disney can't do
stuff as good as they're
doing nowadays?
But it does show that as
a company gets very mature
and the management
gets very, very large,
it's hard to do what would
be, like, risky stuff.
But a company like Universal,
they're are a lot smaller,
and they have a
design team that might
be a 10th of the size of
Walt Disney Imagineering.
And those guys, like you
guys, those are fast thinkers.
And they decide, and they
move very, very fast.
They're doing another
one at Hollywood Studios.
Most recently,
Knott's Berry Farm,
which is a smaller
type of park, opened
an attraction called the
Voyage to the Iron Reef.
And it's a shoot 'em up
ride with a ride conveyance.
Four people sit in a row and
you've got these blaster guns,
and you're shooting scenes.
How many people have
been to Midway Mania
down at Disneyland?
OK.
Visualize a vehicle
that never stops.
The screens are endless.
You don't stop in a scene.
You don't see work lights,
so you don't see the track.
You have guns, and they're
all a different color.
So when you shoot
something, you can
see which color's
getting the most scores
by the way the thing blows up.
And it's got 3D animation,
the best I have ever seen.
And it's a small
company in Toronto,
and they built a whole
attraction like that for, like,
$5 million.
Where somebody else would
spend $100 million, and it's
very complicated.
So getting a chance to go
snoop at all these things,
and of course with Knott's
they said, come on down.
And you help me the
VIP to open the thing
and take the first ride.
And I said, yeah.
Before I do that, I want
to go see everything.
I'm crawling under the
vehicles, and the president's
watching me calling around,
looking at everything.
I want to know how
everything is done,
because that's-- that's a long
winded answer to your question.
I want to know everything
about everything.
AUDIENCE: And then
another quick question
about theme park philosophy.
Like, how do you balance
the need for nostalgia
with the need for something new?
You look at Disneyland.
There's the annual
passholder's there for 60 years
going all the time
on the weekends.
You'll get Disney World.
It's more of a
destination place that you
go to once every few years.
So how do you balance
the old attractions
with the new attractions
in those theme parks?
BOB GURR: This guy's dangerous.
He just asked the question
that's the hardest, hardest
question for anybody in the
theme entertainment industry.
Because on the one
hand, you'll have
a family that loves
an attraction,
and they want to go
every year, and they
don't want it to ever change.
You'll have another family
that goes and that says,
same old stuff.
Why don't they ever
tear that stuff out
and do something neat?
That range is hopeless.
I don't think anybody's
ever going to solve that.
It's a balance.
Because guaranteed, you're
upsetting everybody.
The ones that are upset because
you took it out, and the one's
that are upset because
it's still there.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for being here
and answering our questions.
I have a question
about Halloween.
I wonder if it's a holiday
that you enjoy celebrating.
I know you're an inventor.
So it's coming up
in a few months,
and I wonder if you
had anything to share
about what you've done in
the past to celebrate it.
Things you've invented
or projects you
think we could
possibly do ourselves.
BOB GURR: Halloween.
Yep.
Now you're asking me to
do concept idea stuff.
Now you've got to
bring the concept in,
and I'll make the machine work.
So that question's
a little bit hard.
But Halloween is-- how many
of you know the real history
of Halloween over 100 years?
It has changed completely.
So that nowadays, Halloween
is entirely different.
There's a big Halloween
product display
that I go to every year in LA.
I think it's called ScareLA.
That's the craziest stuff
I've ever seen people do,
and it gets crazier every year.
So I'm aware of it,
but I don't really
know enough to say what's
good or bad or what.
But there's so many people
creating stuff for Halloween.
It's endless.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming
to talk to us, and also for
your contributions to Disney.
There's something about the
physicality of animatronics
that's, for me, totally unique.
I don't get it from video games.
I still don't get
it from movies.
I'm curious how you
think that will change,
and what the exciting
opportunities are
going forward.
So you've got image
and sort of animation
and CGI mixed with
physical rides.
Are there areas you find
particularly exciting?
BOB GURR: Yeah, this march of
storytelling and technology,
it's just constantly
grinding along.
I kind of feel sorry
for folks today,
because you have this
logarithmic curve,
and it's climbing up.
It's so steep that
back in those days,
the curve was way down here,
and in not much effort,
you got really far.
Today, as you know, in
just about every industry,
you've got a curve like this.
It takes so much effort to
hardly make any advance in it.
But it's relentless, it's
slow, and it keeps grinding.
An example of this is what
I was telling you about.
The Voyage to the Iron
Reef is a small company
with some very good
thinkers figuring out
a better way to do a CGI.
And do it so fast that
you shoot something,
and in about a
quarter of a second,
the whole thing
blows up in pieces.
Not a thing where a
little thing falls over
like a shooting gallery.
When I see people that do
that-- and it's a tiny company.
It's only a handful of people.
Those kind of people are
scattered everywhere.
And sometimes a company
will see that they
can take a piece of this and a
piece of that, and with an idea
here and a story
writer there, and they
can make something out of it
that really is mind blowing.
But there's no way
to forecast it,
and it gets very,
very expensive.
Except today, some people are
doing this very inexpensively,
and they're doing
a very good job.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you've
mentioned how you're now
part of the awards
committee and you go around
to all of these new theme
parks who are bringing out
new technologies.
How And you mentioned
also the blaster rides
and stuff that-- shooter
rides that are coming along.
How do you feel about the
way our rides are changing,
and the way that they're
changing the way we experience
these rides?
And do you think there's
anything about that that
won't change moving forward?
Or anything particularly
interesting that will change?
BOB GURR: Oh, I
love this question.
I get this a lot.
It has to do with
attention span.
50 years ago, people would
do any kind of an activity,
and it would be kind of
simple, kind of slow.
They would spend quite a
few minutes at something.
The attention span of
some people I think
is right around 20 seconds.
You know what I'm talking about.
You can be bored
in about 20 seconds
if something is not
really interesting.
The interesting thing
about that is the stuff
that we spend such
a short time at
are usually mind blowing
technical achievements.
And that goes back to this curve
that I was trying to describe.
It's like, how much
more do we have
to do in the face of people
who maybe in 10 years,
they'll be down to 15
seconds before they're bored?
That really impacts
storytelling,
because you can't get people
to sit down and savor a story,
savor all the
subtleties of something.
Everything is going
just like that.
We call it multitasking.
If you stop and think
about what multitasking is,
you're simply using
the same brain
doing one thing, one at a
time, but every five seconds
it's going to another thing.
And you're not doing it
all at once, you know.
You're just processing
this, this, and this
in some kind of a sequence.
The fact that so many people
are used to doing this now-- you
go on any street.
There's a crosswalk.
There's cars coming.
The person's going
across the street.
They've got a device,
stuff stuck in their ears.
They are not looking
in any direction.
They're assuming a
painted white line
will allow them
not to be killed.
[LAUGHTER]
They are so tightly woven
into their electronic world
that they don't even
see a world around them.
You follow what
I'm talking about?
You've got products
and services here
that do a little bit of that,
so I'm not really knocking that.
But--
[LAUGHTER]
You've got to
remember, a theme park,
those are the
customers that come
in there with that type of life
and that type of expectation.
What do you do to get
their attention where
they'll savor the whole idea?
And I've watched
50 years of this,
and it's just a steady trend.
Complicated question,
complicated answer.
So I apologize.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to build
on that question a little bit.
Google started on the web
and we were born to the web,
and the way we
connected with our users
was through the internet.
But increasingly, Google
is expanding what we do
or getting more into
making devices and hardware
and computers, phones.
And so the place where
we reach our customers
isn't always the web.
Sometimes it's a real, physical
place, like a retail store.
Well, the internet wasn't around
when Disneyland and Disney
World were built. And I
imagine, had Walt been around,
he would have been
fascinated by it.
So I guess my
question to you is,
if you were to build a physical
space to bring the web to life
in a real, tangible place,
what would it look like to you?
If that was your job?
BOB GURR: Man, you-- I knew
this place had brilliant people.
Man, these are very
heady questions.
You're getting into
a lot of theory,
a lot of social awareness
of the methodologies
that people use in their lives.
It's a very, very complex mix.
And your trying to approach
that mix with your products
and your services.
I really feel for
the anguish you
must go through trying to
figure out, what do we do,
and how do we really
implement this?
Because number one, you're going
to make some money doing it,
or you're going to just astound
the world if the thing actually
works, which you've
already done.
I don't know how
in the world you
dive into the
psychology of changing
minds over a long period of
time to know just how to specify
the course you want to take.
I'm glad I did all my
design so long ago.
It was a lot easier.
[LAUGH]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BOB GURR: All right.
Ooh, are we running-- ooh, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Last question.
BOB GURR: OK.
You're the last question.
AUDIENCE: So it's sort of two.
But the first one is, so
I love the Jungle Cruise.
That's a nice old ride.
Love taking it.
Love the humor.
Can you convince me that I
shouldn't feel about It's
a Small World like I do?
[LAUGHTER]
What is supposed to be the
magic with It's a Small World?
[LAUGHTER]
BOB GURR: Other than the
music, Richard Sherman who
wrote it is a very
good friend of mine,
and he always opens
his speeches with,
if you love it or
hate it, I'm the guy.
You know.
The whole concept-- that
was a UNICEF concept.
It came to us about
10 and a half months
before the opening date.
It was a show.
We got into it very, very late.
The concept was simple.
The whole world, if
they thought about it,
could connect themselves in
such a normal, peaceful, quiet
manner expressed as children.
That's why we chose one
size head, one size face.
Because we were
running out of time.
We couldn't do it any other way.
And we had only the differences
of singing and clothing,
but the same face.
The whole world
is like the same.
That was the idea.
That was the rationale.
Of course, the world
doesn't always turn out
the way you want to do that.
But some people will
go to the Small World
over and over and over,
and withstand that song--
[LAUGHTER]
Because there's something--
there's a psychological thing
that you pick up, and you don't
know you're picking it up.
It's been discussed a lot by
a lot of people over time.
Interesting that you
would ask that question.
Because in a way, that is
a reverse of the changes
we see with the
technological way
people want to be
entertained and the attention
span getting tighter and tighter
and tighter, and the fact
that you can sit in
that boat, and it's just
a bunch of kids singing.
[LAUGH]
AUDIENCE: And the
second question
I had-- and it's
quick, I'm sure-- was
there sort of a status
symbol attached to what
level of ride your thing got?
Like, your firetruck
would be an A ticket ride.
And, you know, a
roller coaster would
be a D. Was there any sort of
status associated with which
projects you were working on?
BOB GURR: No, because this was
a natural range that you wanted
to do, because you're going to
have A, B, C, D, E. One time
we used tickets like that,
and then it was just,
everything's the same.
So as you know,
in the vernacular,
E ticket is described
by everybody,
because you know
what that meant.
That's the big one, and that.
So we don't really
pay much attention
to the status of things.
Because you need the little
area development things,
you need the little
subtle things
that are quiet to match
the big, rowdy stuff.
So we still look
at it as somebody
says an A, somebody
says an E, we
know exactly what that means.
Because it's the range of
things that guests would enjoy.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
BOB GURR: OK.
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
so much for being here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]